I do have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p call anytime
here's a voicemail i received
hey David uh I know that you guys are
part of the CYT Network and recently
I've seen a lot of decline in the TYT
Network do you feel the affiliation with
the Young Turks can possibly harm the
David Pakman show
hmm especially with some of the recent
things that t wifey has been saying ana
kasparian saying I don't care if you
call me social justice warrior and
basically I kind of do agree with a lot
of other people saying that TYT has
recently become very SJW and do you
think it will affect the show that's it
negatively positively and how long do
you think it would take to affect the
show okay bye David
thank you being part of TYT Network is
not going to affect the David Pakman
show because the David Pakman show is
not part of TYT Network and I like how
this entire voicemail is premise taun
what someone knows I know you're part of
TYT Network
thus a minute and a half of commentary
based on that you don't know that
because it's not true
you thought that but we're not part of
TYT Network so I don't think we are
going to be at all affected Jason by
what's going on on TYT Network be it
positive negative or whatever our
audience thinks about it cuz we are
independent for those that know don't
know what is the TYT Network we're
talking about the Young Turks the young
an online news show they have a number
any number I would say of programs at
this point the main one being the
primary The Young Turks show hosted by
Genki Goran Ana Kasparian no we were we
were part of their YouTube network years
ago and were not in any way you know we
were always produced independently we
have not been part of that TYT Network
for close to two years and I think we
will be completely immune to people's
opinions about that network as long as
people don't misunderstand like this
caller and think that we're part of that
network we're just not that's just the
reality I assume he's a trump supporter
I assume he has nothing to lose no I I
think that that is a
he's a who knows I don't know who that
is and I won't even speculate on the
bonus show today we're going to have a
conversation about the future of the
bonus show in the absence of Lois many
questions about that I will also tell
you about the end of this Mars
simulation that was happening on a
Hawaiian island very very interesting
what has been determined sign up for the
bonus show at david pakman.com slash
membership